There is this technical excitement of
how to really solve such a big
challenging issue. But there is much
more to it than purely a technical
solution. Because once you build a a
relatively uh effective detector, then
you need to integrate it in a kind of uh
enduser tool because we collaborate a
lot with journalists and other kinds of
professionals who want to use these
tools. And uh there you face numerous
other challenges. For instance, how to
really explain the limitations of the
model. Uh how to uh help them translate
what you know an 80% detection score
means. Uh and when to be cautious about
uh the results. So things like that. Um
that's a a very intriguing uh uh kind of
uh collaboration we have with such
people.
[Music]
Akis Papadopoulos, welcome to the human
zero day. Super happy to have you here
with me with us. Thank you so much.
>> Thank you Michael. I'm happy to be here.
You know, Akish, we've been talking in
the series about human vulnerabilities
and human zero days and um the way in
which technology and society is
developing these tools to both protect
and attack the human mind and exploit
human irrationality perhaps or human
decision-m to to enforce some actions.
Um, and much of it has been around deep
fakes. H, and I'm really, really excited
to get your take on the space. You've
been in the world of the intersection of
technology, synthetic media, AI for
quite some time. Uh, really at the at
the edge of it from from quite some time
ago. I believe I saw from um 2020 a a
slide point a shareepoint of a of a
presentation where you were walking
through the emergence of deep fakes and
and the rise of them both in terms of
the you know the the where they are in
the world as well as how they evolve and
technologically. So, a lot for us to
unpack together and tell me a little bit
about yourself and how you even got into
this space of synthetic media.
>> Thank you. You summed it up very well.
It indeed it's uh a few years uh since
uh I've been involved in relevant
research uh on the topic.
Actually the story goes a bit uh um
back um we had a collaborative research
project uh uh in in Europe with uh
several partners uh including for
instance Deutsche and BBC and um at that
time um
we
recognized that a big opportunity is uh
the application of uh automated means
for extracting you know uh trending
topics uh and uh monitoring uh
conversations in social media. We're
talking now about back in 2016 17 but at
the same time uh we saw what happened
with the US uh elections and the rise of
disinformation.
So uh this uh started becoming like a
very clear risk back then. So uh uh
digital disinformation and also uh
augmented with the capabilities of
digital platforms. a couple of years
later this uh uh rapid development of uh
uh generative models. Back at that time
the main technology was generative
adversarial networks which first appear
already in 2014 but uh as of 201617
we started seeing a very high potential
for uh uh realistic images. Uh so you
you may recall a website called this
person does not exist. This was among
the first to uh provide uh access to to
such models. And uh quickly we saw that
for instance adversaries uh created uh
fake avatars and fake accounts using
such images.
And uh this led to the realization that
uh uh this might be a quite uh quite
important problem. The rest is I think
history. You you um we've all seen the
really rapid developments in generative
AI over the last couple of years. And um
what I think makes this uh uh extremely
interesting is this uh um
kind of arms race between uh
new highly realistic synthetic media and
at the same time new methods for
detection uh to to catch up uh with new
developments.
>> Yeah. So tell me about a little bit
about this arms race. Um because also in
the in the presentation that I that I
found, you're talking about these
different detectors like um motion
detectors and eyelinking detectors and
and facial artifacts. What are the
different ways in which we've been using
different artifact finding in order to
detect deep fakes? What's been more or
less effective? And and where are we
today?
>> Yes. Erh well first of all there is a
quite a general category of methods uh
that um uh come from a more traditional
uh forensics uh research um where they
try to identify
um inconsistencies in the in the visual
content. So things that don't match the
the natural uh uh objects or uh subjects
of that are depicted in in image or
video. And this includes things like uh
biometric uh features like eye blinking
uh um like um the position and direction
of different facial landmarks.
H there is also a category of methods
called photoiththesismography.
It's a kind of complicated term which
tries to estimate essentially
the pulse uh of of the subject by visual
analysis of of how the lighting changes
the reflection of lighting. So this
requires quite high quality uh video or
image in order to be uh possible. Same
also for the reflections uh um cor from
the um uh corneal uh part of the eye and
these all um uh assume that you have a a
relatively high resolution uh video to
work with. uh if if if you can um uh
find such uh version of a video then
they are pretty powerful and also pretty
as we say explainable because you can
really see what's the problem but more
often than not uh in uh in the internet
you cannot really uh find a high quality
version most of the times you see a very
highly compressed uh video or low
quality video and that's where
>> and why is that by the way why is
The primary reason is that uh first of
all platforms themselves apply some
standard compression when something is
uploaded.
There are very few platforms uh that
typically are used by professionals but
the mainstream platforms typically
compress in some standard quality. Erh
but there is also uh a tendency for
people you know to download and
re-upload and in that process you know
they might use some uh tools and either
on purpose or without uh knowing they uh
really degrade a lot of the quality of
the video and also uh through that
process they remove the traces that uh
could help us a lot in detecting uh
video as manipulated or as synthetic.
So that's one of the primary practical
challenges
and um this brings us to a second very
big category of methods that are very
popular the more uh deep learning based
methods. So there the idea is that you
give a lot of examples of uh uh
synthetic or manipulated images or
videos and also uh actual authentic
videos and you try to train models that
can separate uh between the two. This is
uh supposedly a bit better because it
can handle uh uh such uh degradations uh
to an extent of course uh through what
we call uh augumentation during
training. So you might give an original
fake video. When I say original, I mean
in its original uh high quality or high
resolution, but you can also
artificially generate multiple versions
of this that are of lower quality. This
is what we call augumentation. So if you
provide the model with this, then it
learns to detect also the lower quality
versions. Um but we see that uh these
kind of methods are also uh sensitive
um because you know there are new
generative models uh that uh come out
every day and uh not only that but there
are also other kinds of transformations
that uh when you train the model you
weren't aware of so that's why we are in
a kind of cat and mouse situation.
>> I love it. So, so Akish, this this is so
helpful to to get a picture of, you
know, where we're at and a little bit
about the ways in which deep fakes are
emerging and then the ways in which we
can tackle the the the detection
process. So, so today you're a principal
researcher with Cir and part of that
you're you're leading the Mever group.
Is that how you say it right? Mever.
>> Mever. Mever. Whatever you prefer.
Um, and so you're leading many engineers
and researchers at this intersection of
AI, synthetic media, bias,
misinformation, etc. You've you're so
you're really living at the edge of
what's happening today. So give me give
me a a you know, a bit of your
perspective of where we're at today, you
know, December 2024 with the state of
deep fakes. you know what what are we
seeing in terms of quality both in terms
of the detection and the generation.
>> First of all in terms of generation
uh we are at a point where uh you know
the level of quality and the realism
is uh extremely high. Uh, of course when
you see a lot of uh if we're talking
about fully synthetic media uh like uh
the kind in images like mid journey uh
and uh Deli3 uh provide
you can often get a kind of plastic or
synthetic feeling when you look at it.
So it's still a bit uh visible in some
cases.
uh although that could be said also for
some kind of artistic photography that
is authentic. So um there are certain uh
boundaries that are very blurry for
human uh inspectors and investigators. I
guess very experienced people can still
tell the difference but I think the
majority of uh of citizens are not uh
very well equipped to tell the
differences in terms of video. Uh again
we see really spectacular video um from
services like uh Sora and Clink and uh
there are uh many uh contenders runway
and uh many other services on the market
and many also open- source uh uh models
that you know uh everyone can download
you know some of them are quite
demanding uh in terms of GPU power but
still they are pretty accessible
especially for people with some
resources.
>> And can you touch on a little bit the
the pace of evolution of the deep fake
generation because you know we've seen a
lot of the these open-source models
emerge like deepace lab and deepface
live and and and those are at this point
a few years old. I'm curious if you're
saying that these these are evolving at
the pace which we expected. Is it
faster? Is it slower?
>> In general uh uh the you know these very
well-known tools like deep face lab they
still evolve.
So in terms of uh tooling uh yes we do
see a lot of uh progress. There is a
tremendous growth in terms of
open-source models, gener generative
models, especially text to image, but
now we are also seeing text to video uh
models. And uh these advances are picked
up by very uh big providers of services
like uh Adobe, like uh open AI and
others. And uh uh they are again uh made
available to to the general public in
very easy to use tools that also offer a
very good control nowadays because one
of the limitations a few years back was
that the process was a bit random. You
couldn't really generate what you wanted
to. But nowadays you have very fine
control over the generative process and
also editing uh tools. Uh so you can
really uh create what you conceive and
um uh this uh of course uh uh makes the
risk of you know creating harmful
content much higher
course. So I I think the the pace of
development at least in the last couple
of years has been higher than I expected
personally. It it was also very hard to
keep up with the latest developments. Uh
so yes it's it's in a way a bit
alarming.
>> Absolutely. And and let's talk a little
bit about then the detection side. So
how what what are you seeing in terms of
the detection? are how good are we today
as a society as an ecosystem in
detecting deep fakes today? Erh I think
it's we are striving uh it's definitely
far from being solved uh even by
bringing the best uh technology in
place. Uh we have realized I think over
the last couple of years that uh you
know constantly training new models to
catch up with the latest developments is
probably not a kind of silver bullet. we
were hoping for. So it's uh uh of course
it is one effective strategy and it's
something that we really need to to be
doing
but at the same time I think there are
other promising uh uh ways of of trying
to solve the problem. One of these that
some people have already presented in uh
conferences in the area is instead of
trying to detect fakes to try to verify
that something is authentic. So the
reverse problem
but this is equally challenging uh
because you know uh there is a really in
terms of machine learning when you try
to learn a very specific class it's much
easier when you compared to when you try
to learn everything else. Uh so we are
in the situation where you know trying
to learn what is real is is a bit of a
challenge. There is also some help in
this by the uh foundational models or
multimodel foundational models like uh
for instance uh clip uh by open AI and
uh other uh related uh uh big models
that essentially have been pre-trained
on essentially the whole uh
web of images and videos. And because
they have been trained on such a large
uh um volume of media, they can encode
the characteristics of what is a typical
uh uh what is a typical uh uh media
assuming that the majority of this media
is not synthetically generated. So uh if
if we pre-train them today uh uh on the
whole web, I suspect that we have a very
uh mixed uh um uh input of synthetic and
real real media.
>> Absolutely. And so I'm I'm hearing you
talk about the arms race and the the
fact that we realize that there's no
silver bullet, but at the same time
there are varying effective strategies
that need to be used together and and it
also sounds like the space is quickly
evolving. So you're almost talking about
it like we're in the beginning of it and
uh not uh you know a lot of people are
are are looking around and are saying
okay you know where's this heading and
what's going to happen and and in both
the generation the detection and what it
sounds to me listening to you is saying
well you know it's it's evolving it's
it's evolving and we're learning and and
both on on every front. Um, you know,
tell me in in a couple words, what do
you get most excited by in in your line
of work with SR and uh with me?
>> You mean in this area or in general?
>> Well, but either in this area or in
general? Well, in this area, I think uh
of course there is this technical
excitement of how to really solve such a
big challenging issue. But there is much
more to it than purely a technical
solution because once you build a a
relatively effective detector then you
need to integrate it in a kind of uh end
user tool because we collaborate a lot
with journalists and other kinds of
professionals who want to use these
tools and there you face numerous other
challenges. for instance, how to really
explain the limitations of the model. Uh
how to uh help them translate what you
know an 80% detection score means. Uh
and when to be cautious about uh the
results. So things like that. Um
>> that's a a very intriguing uh uh kind of
uh collaboration we have with such
people. And uh of course uh there are
also uh other uh other other challenges
because you ultimately want to also help
citizens be able to to detect uh or at
least uh be protected by such uh risks
and there I think we are still in a very
preliminary
uh stage. So, a lot of interesting stuff
ahead,
>> a lot of interesting stuff. And I think
that we can certainly expect looking
forward how
almost every digital interaction we will
have will include some form of new user
interface or user experience that will
help us engage with this question of am
I looking at something that's authentic
synthetic real fake you know there's so
many terminologies to be used but but
you know when it when it comes down to
it it's really about do we have the
tools as a societ society to be able to
engage digitally either with information
online or with the information we get in
our business sense like a real-time
communication like what we're doing now
that we can trust it to be authentic. So
ak with that I I want to thank you and
sharing
continue doing amazing work. I'm going
to continue following from the side and
thank you for an awesome conversation.
>> Thank you as well. I was uh very glad to
be a doctor with you.